hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today
i am giving away some outriders pc codes
i did a charity stream last week for
ablegamers which is an organization that
helps disabled gamers play video games
and reached out to square enix and was
like hey do you have any codes that i
could give away to people
um to support the charity stream for
people who can't watch streams i thought
that i would give away
three codes here on youtube full details
will be at the end of the video and in
the description but for now enjoy
this outriders pc gameplay where all of
my settings
were on ultra oh my gosh it's
a pizza oh i'm having i'm having a bit
of a
bit of a frame rate is happening do i
look cool
you look like a destiny oh yeah i want
to see the nitro rifle
oh you really do you walk straight out
of destiny dude yeah like you can only
be in destiny if you can't see out of
your helmet i feel like that's a
yeah general rule stay still
yeah no that's that's like just metal do
you think i'm cute
would you like on a date with me do you
think i could get chicks
your character looks pretty cool that's
my impersonation of the main character
hey shira geared up and tracking down
jacob let's run down these stairs and go
to the next mission
yeah he's ready to descend the hounds
warehouse
i like your performance better then
one but again i do it does to me sound
so much
like uh a non-american trying to do an
american accent
yeah credit card hamburger
where are we going to now i love it
oh nope that was bad
oh nice we just sniping out here that's
what's happening
oh yeah we're sniping oh yeah dude
sniping this is pretty sick
nope that's a shoulder i'm missing
snipes too yeah me too it's fine
that was too at the same time it reminds
me of my friday night
protect me oh well i keep for some
reason not even looking at the reticle
correctly that's that's entirely on me
yeah hey something you got to figure out
in your own [ __ ] can you shut your mouth
and nobody asks you okay
oh whoops i thought this was the
bathroom
yeah chat i am waiting for the day that
somebody tries to cost me as a valley
in anything and i get to be like oh my
god
no like where does this belong in a
video game though
i don't know you could voice like a
maybe
maybe
it's like a pixar character or a
dreamworks character in the future for
you there you go
yeah yeah all right yeah you know what
if they often
maybe i'd take it or you know what
valley girl on the next gta
right that's good actually i could pitch
that to rockstar
yeah valley girl in the next skyrim
i love that even more elden ring
she's just there for some reason he
shouldn't be down here
and then oh my god no it's the dude
there's like one dude
that's even seen inside me who keeps
saying you have a heart of gold
and it's like the way he says it is such
a yeah don't let them take it from you
you have a heart of gold and it always
sticks in my head because he says it's
so much like it's a song
thomas come on baby anyone want to
teleport to camp
yeah is that what we're trying to do oh
you got a cool helmet
thank you it's the only one i found is
your face supposed to be showing
uh well i didn't seem to have any other
option in the menu okay and having
full face yeah it is supposed to be
showing i felt like it was a helmet that
probably covered your face but maybe
it's a bug but no
why would you want to cover this
beautiful face my friend um you guys
trying to
maybe like carve a pot to the solo tower
and chill or like what
sure let's do that touch the demon
inside me
oh god i love her so much dude
they really um quarantine you upped the
up the appearance with the wax on her
eyes yeah
sure did huh very visceral yeah
makes you think makes you think
[Laughter]
really [ __ ] makes it
[Music]
it's a good game though that demon soul
that's a good
game good game it's a good ass [ __ ]
game all right all i'm gonna say is
three
is i think that the penetrator
can go [ __ ] himself that dude
oh yeah it's super rude but i but i
saved homeboy so
you have to save homeboy or i feel like
that fight without homeboy
must be so so so hard which homeboy
the homeboy who helps you in that fight
he'll spawn in there
no uh it's not a summon yeah yeah
what's his name i don't remember his
[ __ ] time doll
no it's like it's like frying or
thrive or there we go where is he
you are you're on the right path in the
dungeon he's in the dunk
yeah the lock door he'll like talk to
you from behind it you have to like go
around the other side and
oh no get him out of there i am i let
him die i think
he can indeed die oh man i'm doing so
well
are you no oh
[Laughter]
man come harvest over here get your
harvesting materials
there's a man there's a man oh no
there's two men there's three men oh
there this is a lot of men
you know what i'm gonna do nice
oh and they're on fire oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh my god
standing outside the bubble like what
the [ __ ] i'm leaving holy [ __ ]
that was amazing i got called in on my
day off
we froze them lit them on fire and then
turned them into skeletons
wow very sorry every element
we have a boss fight in here don't we
yeah this is a box what
this is where the uh the demo ended yeah
you're right wow we go through that
all right i hope those things don't fly
off the
nah they seem pretty sturdy we also
missed a uh a
side quest we did miss the side quest
that's right the one that was in that
person on the ground
yeah after that she was like i'm about
to die you must
like thank you
[Laughter]
all right gauss i don't get it oh i
didn't hit that one
run away from his electricity get away
from god it's
very [ __ ] it's just really open oh
wow that was really op
what the [ __ ] holy [ __ ] did he do that
much damage last time
what the [ __ ] no he didn't little
headies right there chad little head
that's great yeah we love little protect
me
i love john just always runs in there
and protects me
punches the ground and yells protect me
i'm not sure how you want me to do that
john but i'm trying
my best i believe we even hit phase two
of i think we're going to kill him
before it's nuts how op he was in that
one sitting
and now we're fine like
okay that one move he had that was
ridiculous yeah do you think he's just
you just took him in that
butt ooh he resisted some kind of effect
oh that's it this is it i forgot about
this
[ __ ] not today you stupid [ __ ]
i will restock okay great
back in action let's go through this
camera
oh he's dead sweet all right how do i do
the sizzle what is the emote for the
sizzle
oh i don't know how to do emojis hold v
hold v
on v it's not vegan it is v for me you
just hold v no it's f
f definitely v f
is availability continues to be the
worst gamers of all time holy [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] doing everything but
the right thing
yeah there you got it jon
oh dude we can high five oh my god okay
let's time it let's time it
i feel like you may be too close okay oh
on three
one two three oh not what i was off the
that's not what i was offering which
one's a high five
it's the one that looks like a high five
to the left yeah yeah okay
shut up andy you pressed the melee
button like a little brother who's like
how did how'd you do that though okay
okay one two
three uh one more one more
okay on three right one might go on
three two
three oh i didn't i didn't select it
probably that's my bad try it again
[Music]
one two three
my wow yeah hell yeah all right now
how'd you do it though
no anyway let's move on we got people to
shoot
it's all f4 andy
speaker you little freakers we get an
achievement if all three of us do
a high five together here right here
high five high five time okay okay okay
on three oh wait all of us do we get we
getting yeah apparently apparently
all right here we go one two three
go oh it wasn't in sync but we did get
it
the accolade's completed yeah it says
that it says actually completed
a nightmare that's what i got oh again
you wanna do it again
one two three i just slapped you in the
side of the head okay okay okay you did
one
two three oh that was pretty good it was
like a little circle of
high fives yeah like a wave like a
baseball crap yeah that was sick
key wow i'm missing a lot of yours
so sorry to everybody no i am i mean i'm
hitting them but just not
nope didn't hit that one just not in the
face because they they really they are
all of them [ __ ] oh you did that
yeah it is tremendously helpful all
right i'm gonna go freeze this big boy
maybe
just sort of [ __ ] around i have my
rocket shuttle man's skeleton
oh my god dude holy [ __ ]
you think he's dead holy [ __ ] dude
there's rules healing removes toxic
status are you trying to tell me i'm
toxic [ __ ] sake man
[ __ ] good shot [ __ ] you're still alive
this bot
okay the boss is dead yeah you're just
being chased by that tornado dude
it's like right on ya yeah we do
um there's one of the bosses is dead
there were multiple captains
i think there's only two there right oh
yeah
okay hang on i can do this and then i
can do
oh it's rocket launcher time it's rocket
launcher time
i need help oh he's got to be dead is he
dead he's got to be killed
yes i don't want to use my all this
oh and i have to use my help here we go
there you go buddy i got you up there
friend
get [ __ ] on uh i said that the way my
character would holy [ __ ] we killed you
you're not technically wrong so i just
got disconnected
oh no oh no the explosion went off and
the screen went black
and then it said internet connection
okay we can probably immediately invite
you back right i don't feel like yeah i
have a feeling it wasn't an internet
connection error
like you know they've been dealing with
all the issues and it's kind of like
communicating it with the
community they're like today we're we're
about to perform the mother of all turn
it off and turn it on again
that's cute this oh this area is so open
john think of all the loot we might be
able to get
you know it kicked me again i got dc'd
again i might not
keep going i might have to switch back
over to dark souls
that checks out that's that's some real
john smith [ __ ]
it's also taking a long time for me to
join and i feel like it's broken
i'm just gonna do this until we die
that's all i'm saying you know not
supposed to be doing it by myself
but here we are oh it's a boss fight
this might be a bad idea
no i'll be fine it's not ideal
but i think i'll be oh my god i didn't
expect you to have that kind of range on
spam all right
oh boy it's got elements going on with
him
you know he leave me alone
okay nope too many of them too many of
them too many
[ __ ] ah i got stuck on a wall uh
no no no no
this is not designed for one player [ __ ]
all right die die die die everybody die
wasted that that's not good
the lack of ammo is also a problem that
is consistent
oh oh oh okay okay okay we can do this
reload faster you stupid [ __ ] come on
just die just die just die just die just
die just die
did i get him can i get him did i get
him not quite yet
not quite i think i did okay
he's a real gamer alice you know what i
mean all right well we've done it
that's great love that for us um yeah
this game is fun the combat is fun
i'm just not super into the world i
think it's my big thing like i like some
of the design but i'm not like
grabbed by it if you know what i mean
and that is
it for the outriders gameplay from the
last stream now
if you want to win one of three
outriders pc only codes
i need you to leave a comment here on
youtube telling me who your favorite
outriders class is or who you would
choose to play as
and why i'm going to pick whatever i
think is the funniest answer
but you will have to leave a link to an
instagram page or twitter where you have
open dms so that i can actually message
you to give you the code
people super frequently miss giveaways
because they don't give me a means to
contact them privately to give them the
code and i will give you until sunday to
submit your answers so sunday at midday
uh will be closed and then i will
probably at some point during the
following week
go through the answers pick the ones i
like and give a winner their coat
i highly encourage you guys to check out
the link in the description for where
you can donate to ablegamers as well but
that is it for me today everyone
i hope the three of you who get codes
enjoy them and i will see you guys next
time bye